yeah about when I got that email that
said oh by the way there's gonna be no
screening for Hellboy in Seattle so
there that is I was like I it's not
looking good Hellboy again all right so
this Hellboy is a reboot or at least
retelling of Hellboy is a cinematic
adaptation of the comic book that's not
linked to the Guillermo del Toro movies
this time we have David Harbor as
Hellboy Hellboy's a little demon that
was found in World War two and now he's
grown up around people he's part of this
organization that does paranormal
research and wipes out demons and now we
have Milla Jovovich who plays his blood
queen she's gonna come back and world's
gonna end okay only Hellboy can stop her
let's go okay gonna be real when I was
watching this movie I was like I don't
get why a lot of people hate this I'm
having some fun with it that does go
away by the end but for a section a
portion of this movie I was like I don't
get the big down and get the huge
problem I'm just saying there's
enjoyment threaded in this mess first of
all David Harbor is a good pick to be
cast as hell boy I think he would have
been better if he had more to work with
like if the minds behind this movie were
more in line with good storytelling it's
like everything good in this movie was
good in concept and I kind of fell into
that for a bit and then it started to
melt away it was like oh no like there's
a scene where he fights these three
giants in a field in concept it's really
cool like the rock music kicks on he's
just massacring these giant you can see
how powerful he is you get a pretty
entertaining fight clearly on a green
screen cuz oh my god that was on a green
screen look good CGI does not mean good
movie but when this bad CGI that does
stick out like a sore thumb this movie
does have some bad CGI also the violence
is just it's violent for the sake of
violence like the violence doesn't serve
a purpose will bring up the Netflix
Castlevania series in Episode one of the
Netflix Castlevania series there's a
massacre that happens in this town but I
feel like it was for a point in purpose
first of all because it's an animation
so they have to let the audience know
hey this isn't a cartoon it's an
animation we will take it there if we
need to but also you have to get the
feeling Oh men women children everyone's
being wiped out everyone's in danger and
it's gonna be bad but when the violence
is happening in this movie it's just
violence for the sake of violence um
more blood and people being ripped in
half and the screen and and violence hey
cuz blood and we're rated R now I
already
who is rated R because they said [ __ ]
enough times for it to be rated R pretty
early on in the movie you don't need to
prove it with hyper violence I'm just
saying if you're gonna have hyper
violence have it be for a point or at
least have it be stylistic like example
there is a stylistic violence shot in
the movie where Hellboy goes blam and
then it zooms out through the hole in
the head and the person falls over I was
like that was pretty stylistic I like
that granted it happened at the end of
the movie but it was pretty stylistic
recive is just bloody crap for the sake
of who look at the blood some of the
designs in this movie were interesting
some of the designs were just they were
kind of shitty if not gross like this
girl can like have ghosts come out of
her mouth but you would think it would
be missed like that miss that that's
attached to a torso of a ghost it's not
it's like some weird membrane that looks
like the ass of the alien queen from the
movie aliens even if that's canonically
in line with the comic book which I
don't know if it is make a change you
say it was gross also the editing the
stitching the weaving of the story it's
pretty sloppy in this movie there are so
many people to talk to in so many
different locations so many locations to
go to to get all the pieces of this
puzzle I think they could have focused
that up there are a couple scenes for I
was like that really it didn't serve
much of anything you could cut that out
which also brings up another point this
movie feels a bit too long but it's like
in-between these locations shifts they
didn't know how to get the people there
so a couple times just like all will
just have Hellboy pass out and then he
will be in another location because
someone will have taken him there or it
just does some voiceover montage like on
the Third Age of this and that and you
see people walking another there how
long have to take him to get there I
don't know I suppose is a byproduct
there's a lot of story a lot of
backstory a lot of [ __ ] that happened in
the year 500 so you got to give the
audience a lot of information that
happens from the get-go it's like this
weird storytelling eyesore that happens
early on it just kind of follows the
movie throughout who ever weaved this
movie together just didn't do the
smoothest job there's actually a villain
arc who's the most interesting villain
in the movie he's a pig but I was more
attached to the pig and his axe he has
to grind against Hellboy then Miss Blood
Queen then the movie was like all right
whatever push him to the side we're
gonna go ahead and wrap up his arc in a
very own fulfilling way because now you
have bigger villain Blood Queen come on
guys but no bigger villain does not mean
better villain I was more attached to
the pig
give me the pig like the best scene a
moment in this movies when Hellboy's met
with his moral dilemma the same one he
had in the guillermo del toro Hellboy
and it was done better and
hello boy with more impact this one was
just kind of like hey here's a 99-cent
version of that moral dilemma I thought
to myself if I have friends over and we
have the drinks flowing am I actually
ever going to watch this movie again
probably not it kind of reminded me a
fan for stick are we still calling with
that where's like in concept I see what
they wanted to do with it but in
execution not really I'm just saying I'm
not gonna remember this in t-minus one
day yep I already forgot which is a
bummer because there were a couple
things I liked in the movie whatever
alright so the new Hellboy have you seen
it what did you think of it or the old
one what did you think of it whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want it see more click
right here to see more
[Music]